All right, everyone. I am home alone
again, which means I was faced with a
very tough decision, aka either whip out
the or record another YouTube video. And
uh I guess I'm deciding to feel
productive at the moment. So, I will be
talking about Cassandra in this one.
I've been looking forward to this video
for a couple of weeks because I find
that um you know, like I said, the whole
reason I made this channel in the first
place was that they don't go that
indepth into actual technologies in most
systems design channels or resources.
looking at things like systemsexpert.io.
Like, you know, there's just like no
in-depth stuff about specific
technologies. And I pretty much want to
go through every popular database and
compare its pros and cons cuz I think
you're going to look pretty damn smart
if in an interview you can actually
compare why you might use something like
Cassandra versus Ryak or I don't know,
MongoDB or anything. So, anyways, let's
get into it. Um, and then uh yeah, we
can uh keep going into more technologies
and more deep dives into concepts. All
righty. So episode 19, this one is about
Apache Cassandra. So what is Cassandra?
It is a NoSQL wide column database
designed for really high read and
especially right throughput. Um it was
created at Facebook, modeled after
things like Amazon's Dynamo database and
Google's big table and it's since become
open- source under the Apache license.
Um so yep, like I said, really high
write throughput, no SQL database,
pretty simple stuff. I'm now going to
get into how it goes ahead and does all
of that because it builds upon all the
concepts that we've discussed so far.
Okay, so what is the general design
philosophy of Cassandra? Well, generally
speaking, obviously they want super high
availability. You know, the ability to
scale at a linear rate, meaning every
single time you add a node, it's going
to, you know, do that much work and, you
know, get all of its possible
throughput. Um but most importantly the
thing with Cassandra is that unlike SQL
um it is designed solely for single
partition reads and writes. It doesn't
mean that you can't do reads over say
multiple partitions or can't write to
multiple partitions at a time. But
generally speaking the main usages of a
data database like this are to try and
keep everything onto one partition so
that you don't have that extra network
delay and coordination overhead required
of something like an atomic commit or
having to do all these multiple
partition rights. So like I said,
Cassandra is optimized for a single
partition um operation. Okay. So in
terms of data organization, like I said,
this is a wide column store. So what
that means really is that you have a
primary T or what Cassandra calls it is
known as a partition key and a bunch of
other columns which are basically
arbitrary. You can also specify in your
Cassandra setup some other columns known
as um clustering keys but uh those are
basically um acting as indexes and I'll
discuss those later. Okay. So in terms
of the storage engine like I said
Cassandra is optimizing for really fast
writes because in certain applications
with a ton of users you need to be able
to write quickly and SQL doesn't always
support that especially because of the
fact that it uses B trees. So if you've
watched my first video on this channel,
I discuss the different ways that
databases handle reads and writes and
there are two main types of engines B
treebased and also LSM treebased.
Cassandra goes ahead and uses an LSM
treebased table. The reason that these
are so fast is because it means that
writes get buffered to an in-memory uh
tree. In addition,
uh you know the the downside of this is
that depending on how often log
compaction is performed, remember that
every single write goes into this table,
even if it's just an update, and then
eventually will get compacted to only um
contain the most updated version of a
key. But again, depending on how often
lag uh log compaction is performed, and
this is something that uses a bunch of
CPU resources in the back, um you know,
obviously updates can take a decent
amount of extra disk space as a result
of that. Additionally, performance of
reads compared to B trees can be a
little bit slower if you need to search
through a key through the SS tables, but
Cassandra does use an algorithm called
Bloom filters, which basically is an
optimization on um doing these reads
because it approximates the contents of
a set. And that way you can guess if an
SS table contains a specific key. Okay,
in terms of partitioning, why is
Cassandra good? Um, well, Cassandra uses
the partitioning key in accordance with
um, consistent hashing. So, I literally
covered this two videos ago as a
prerequisite for this video in order to
basically say that consistent hashing
tries to um, put all of the the
partitions on machines in a way such
that when new nodes are added or nodes
are removed from a cluster, there's
minimal rebalancing of rows. Okay, so
hopefully that makes sense. In terms of
replication, this is where Cassandra is
really really um making uh for good
write speeds. It's a Dynamo style
database. So what that means is that
every single write as opposed to just
being sent to one leader node is being
sent to every single node in the cluster
for that partition. So what that means
though is that um you know obviously a
that can introduce conflicts and b it's
a question of well at what point after
hearing from all of these uh nodes do we
actually tell our client that a right
was successful and the answer to that
second question um is that rights are
only reported back to the client as
successful once a right reaches a number
of nodes that is preconfigured by the
database administrator. Cassandra has a
ton of options for this. So you can
either just hit literally any one node.
You can hit um you know say a quorum of
nodes but only in your local data
center. You can hit an actual global
quorum of nodes and there are a bunch of
options for this. So you know you can
kind of configure that to get the
consistently consistency level that you
want. Um additionally just by virtue of
being a um replication setup where there
are multiple leaders it means that there
are going to be conflicting rights. So
how do we handle these? Well we use last
right wins. last right wins means that
um you know based on the higher time
step uh based on the higher time stamp
whichever one was the more recent right
is the one that is kept. However, the
issue here is that if you've seen my
videos in the past, clocks are not
reliable in distributed systems. Servers
are inherently going to be a little bit
out of sync. Cassandra doesn't really
have a great answer to this. All they
basically say is keep your servers as
close to the proper time as possible via
the NTP network time protocol syncing
mechanism. And um that's really all you
can do there. Another thing that means
is that certain rights might just be
lost if you're going to update a key and
then someone else updates it literally a
millisecond later. So uh that is just a
downside of all this. There's no like
merge handling or anything like that. Um
additionally there is read repair on
reads in order to keep the data
consistent. So if you have um two nodes
where one of them is holding an older
version of a row based on the time stamp
and a client reads from both of those
replicas because um all reads are going
to multiple replicas. Uh the client will
go ahead and perform read repair and
give the replica with the outdated
version of the row the newer version of
the row. Um, additionally, and this is
what um is really done to guarantee
eventual consistency is that Cassandra
runs an anti-entropy process, which
means that in the background um the
replicas are going to be uh kind of
calculating the differences between them
in terms of their contents and then one
replica will help to update another to
make sure it has the most up-to-date
versions of all the data. Okay. And then
the final thing is that um you know in
order to in accordance with kind of
replication Dynamo style databases and
just keeping things available if for
some reason the replicas can't handle
writes in a given moment perhaps um you
know they are overloaded or they're down
the coordinator node that is going to
actually be sending the rights to the
replicas will just store the right for a
period of time and then eventually store
them in the replica when the replicas
are back up. That's known as a hinted
handoff. I've used that term in the
past. Okay. In terms of fault tolerance,
well, like I said, the data is stored on
replicas, which is generally the way
that you do handle fault tolerance. And
that's in this case both good for writes
and reads because writes only have to go
to a certain percentage of the nodes.
Reads only go to a certain percentage of
the nodes and then the data is redundant
via the replicas. Uh the replicas should
allow read and write throughput to scale
linearly with the number of replicas
like I mentioned earlier. And then also
a cool thing about Cassandra is that you
can actually choose the replication
topology. So what that means is not only
can you choose how many nodes is a given
piece of data replicated to but also the
location of which nodes it's going to be
replicated to. So say you want to ensure
that um if an entire server rack or an
entire data center goes down and at
least one replica will still be standing
with that data you can actually use a
replication topology that ensures that
only nodes and say like different
physical locations are being replicas of
one another. Additionally, um, in terms
of detecting faults in, uh, in nodes, we
use a gossip protocol to do that. That
was the subject of the last video on
this channel. And basically, all that
happens is nodes are going to keep track
of heartbeats that they get from other
nodes. And then each node locally is
holding what it assumes to be the last
known heartbeat of every single other
node, which they pass around via this
Gossip protocol. And if the time stamp
takes too long or or it's been too long
since a node has sent out a heartbeat,
uh you know the local node will assume
that other remote node to be dead.
Okay, indexes uh indexes are a really
important part of you know ensuring fast
read performance and it's something I've
talked about on the past in this
channel. The thing is though in terms of
indexes, Cassandra does not let you do
any global secondary indexes. What does
that mean? It means that there's like I
said no index to quickly um filter based
on say some column that isn't the
primary key and do so in a way that it
touches all partitions. Those indexes
are local only which means they only
apply to one partition at a time. So in
order to do these Cassandra is allowing
you to index based on those clustering
keys. And so what it'll do is it'll sort
internally. Um if you have multiple
clustering keys such that you know you
want to keep multiple copies of the
sorted data, Cassandra will actually
denormalize the data and duplicate it on
a given node such that um now you have
two copies of the data sorted in two
different ways. The one issue with this
is even though reads are now going to be
faster for that um value of the
clustering key um the issue here is that
now writes are going to take longer
because we're updating two copies of the
data at once.
Okay. So now let's actually talk about
the use cases for Cassandra because like
I said there's sometimes where it's not
always the perfect solution. There's no
database that's always the right answer
but Cassandra can be the right answer a
lot of the time. So let's discuss when
it is. Big thing as you can see I've got
it written in all caps right here. Write
heavy applications. So if data is
generally self-contained, which you
should be able to do because or I
shouldn't say you should be able to do,
but if there's little relationships uh
within each piece of data and you know
you can kind of keep it all into one row
and keep in mind Cassandra allows you to
use pretty complex data structures in
the rows like arrays and sets and all of
these things. So if you can keep all the
data to one row and rarely have any
associations with things in another
partition or another table and in
addition it only needs to be generally
fetched by itself
then Cassandra might be the solution for
you. So what are examples of this things
like sensor readings? you would use the
same partition key for the same exact
sensor and then all the readings from
that sensor are going to be on the same
partition and then perhaps you would use
a clustering uh you know like an
ordering key like a time stamp so that
you could order them quickly by time and
then filter that way. Same goes for chat
messages. Perhaps a partition key would
be like the chat ID and then time stamp
of the message again in order to sort
them properly. And then the same goes
for user activity tracking. Use the user
ID as the partition key and then again
time stamp furthermore. So, as you can
see, all of these applications right
here where you're just taking in like a
huge list of data and you're really just
going to basically grab chunks of that
list. It's really great for Cassandra.
And of course, in any application,
there's inevitably going to be many
databases used. So it's fine if for say
you just want to use Cassandra for say
like let's do Facebook Messenger
Cassandra for the messages but then you
use a relational database for actually
like the users and the members of a
given chat. So you know you would have a
chat ID that's specified somewhere in
the relational table and then you would
actually be holding all of the chat
messages in something like Cassandra.
That would be a great place to use it.
Okay. So in conclusion, Cassandra is
really good for writeheavy applications
at massive massive scale. Um it can
scale a lot because you can just add
nodes and then the fact that they're
using this Dynamo inspired um design
just allows you to go ahead and make
more writes to different nodes. You've
got anti-entropy in order to keep
everything eventually consistent. Um so
like I said, messaging, sensor readings,
activity tracking, great. Uh the
pitfalls on the other hand are the lack
of strong consistency. Yes, you can
always use quorum reads and writes.
However, uh the issue there is like I
said, even quorums themselves aren't
strongly consistent due to race
conditions and the fact that there's
hinted handoff and the fact that
sometimes um you know, if you make a
right to um like a quorum of nodes, but
you don't actually hit that like quorum
threshold of nodes, then do we revert
the right on the existing nodes that the
rights exceeded on or not? So, quorums
aren't perfect. Just keep that in mind
even if you do want strong consistency
here. And then secondly, obviously if
you want to support things like one to
many relationships and many many to many
relationships, especially spanning
multiple partitions, Cassandra is
probably not going to be the thing for
you. And then finally, we also have a
lack of global secondary indexes. So in
some very specific read heavy
applications where you really want to be
optimizing on read performance and say
like a cache isn't going to work for
you, then Cassandra probably isn't the
move and we're going to have to examine
other options for those. Well guys, like
I said, I hope um this video is useful.
I really hope that uh these like actual
specific technology breakdowns are kind
of the differentiator between my channel
and other existing systems design videos
because I just don't think they go
in-depth enough in terms of actual real
world applications. And I think that
being able to know these things would
really set you apart in a real systems
design